greetings I am The Caretaker a powerful
virtual construct created by the Eldon
to monitor all scientific experiments on
the planet Nexus excuse my erratic
behavior but it seems that I have
developed certain instabilities since
the Elden long ago I am responsible for
analyzing the physical and mental of
sentient organisms such as yourselves it
is important that I clearly understand
the potential of my subjects in order to
best determine how to oh my are you
ready
then please step forward into this
virtual adventure in order to begin
don't be alarmed the experience will be
extension your group will be subjected
to a variety of climates environments
and situations all chosen specifically
to success will require more than skill
in combat during your experience you and
your companions will be expected to make
critical decisions that require both
intelligence and intuition choose well
and be rewarded choose poorly every
choice leads to a new eventualities and
every venture allottee a new choice and
the best part you can experience them
over and over and over
again thank you for participating in
this experiment I have learned a great
deal and I am certain that we will meet
again very soon